It's time to play, eBay Price
is Right RNC Edition.
(cheers and applause)
(contestants whooping)
Jon! Jon!
The biggest challenge for any
presidential candidate
is getting young people
amped up to vote,
which is why their campaigns
sell hot swag
like Donald Trump hats,
Carly Fiorina tees,
Marco Rubio ear flaps,
and Mike Huckabee thongs!
So we're going to show you
a selection of the wei--
Just sit with it--
we're going to show you
a selection
of the weirdest campaign
(bleep), for 250 points,
whoever comes closest
to the real price wins
the chance to pick
the next president.
First up, a fine gift for the
Rand Paul aficionado
in your life, right here:
an enormous Rand Paul
birthday card.
It's a three-foot-tall card
that comes
with a three-foot-tall
card envelope.
The front says, "There's one
thing I have to say to you,"
as if Rand Paul has ever
just said one thing.
Comedians, how much did they
want for this strange gift?
Jon Heder?
Uh, $11.20...
(audience shouting)
Oh, no.
Oh, my God, listen to this.
-That's a lot of pressure.
-Geez.
Go up? You haven't even heard
my original bid.
-(audience shouting)
-Go up?
-Okay. A hundred dollars.
-All right.
-A hundred dollars.
-Pretty good guess.
A hundred dollars.
(applause)
Will Sasso, Will Sasso.
What do you think?
-(audience shouting)
-I don't-I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't... way up.
Way... Way up.
Uh, one dollar, Drew.
(applause)
One dollar.
All right.
Chris D'Elia?
(audience shouting)
Okay, without going over, uh...
without going over, right?
Uh, okay, okay, okay, uh...
all right, all right, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, $14.5 million.
$14.5 million.
(cheers and applause)
All right, the, uh...
the closest without going
over the answer was $35.
Will Sasso gets the point!
D'ELIA:
That's really cheap for that.
-Well, that's what you do.
-(cheering)
Just one dollar.
-Wow, wow, wow.
-Just one dollar.
-They told me to.
-A really low...
that's a really low price.
Next up, we have another piece
of unofficial merch,
a one of a kind
Ted Cruz face dildo.
Now, it's...
(audience yelling and laughing)
D'ELIA:
Wow. Wow.
HARDWICK: This is a prototype
from their Indiegogo campaign
and they say...
HARDWICK (reading):
It's all there.
How much did they ask for an
early release Ted Cruz dildo?
Will Sasso?
(audience shouting)
Uh... I...
Last time I went dildo shopping,
uh, I would have...
(hisses)
Ooh, one like that.
You wouldn't happen to know
what-what grade of plastic
that's made out of?
-Never mind, um...
-(Hardwick laughs)
Um... hmm, I'm gonna say,
I'm gonna say a-around...
around $50.
$50.
All right.
(cheers and applause)
Chris D'Elia.
Okay, look, I know, look,
all right, look, look,
look, look.
Guys, guys, guys, guys, chill.
I mean, that's the most rare
thing I've ever seen in my life.
HEDER:
That could be anyone.
I honestly think the only way
you could get that
is if you sell your soul,
so your soul.
HARDWICK:
Your soul.
-SASSO: Your eternal soul.
-Soul!
HARDWICK:
All right, your eternal soul.
Soul!
I just said, "Soul," dude.
Jon Heder, $50 and soul.
What do you think?
It's an Indiegogo project,
so it's probably, like, free.
HARDWICK:
You think free?
For right now, right now.
-Okay, so you're saying free.
-Yeah.
You're saying $50.
You're saying soul.
The correct answer is $40.
Jon Heder, 'cause he was
-the only one who didn't
go over. -Yeah! (whoops)
-I was so close! -So close.
-I would think a soul would be
-worth more than $40.
-Do I get it?
Yeah, you actually...
-Is that the prize?
-Yes, you get the prize.
I will remove mine
at the commercial break
-and give it to you.
-Oh.